let's get creative check out this fun
idea hey drew it's me dennis and andrew
aka the crafty lumberjack today we're
going to show you an easy and festive
way on how to display all those holiday
cards first you want to start with a
branch or a birch log that you can
purchase at a craft store and drill some
holes in it yup you want three evenly
spaced out holes on the bottom we're
actually going to hang garland from
there and then one hole on the top right
in the middle we're actually going to
use the top of an old hanger for that
and just screw it right in but we're big
fans about using what you have in your
home so you can even use a hook for this
or even some twine to hang and now time
for the garland we're just using some
faux garland and cutting them into about
three foot long pieces and then hot
gluing them right into the holes but
here's an opportunity to bring real
garland into your home you can of course
use real greenery bring some of that
outside in and that's pretty much it now
you're ready to hang on your wall now to
attach the cards to the greenery we're
going to keep it easy and use
clothespins yes but we have to bling
them up a little bit we're going to be
using a little bit of washi tape for
that you know it's all about the details
during this time of year yes so festive
so beautiful you can customize this
personalize it however you'd like but it
really is the perfect way to display all
those thoughtful holiday cards you've
received this year happy holidays
that's
genius why didn't i think of that
[Music]